the opening scene features so Yan a kind
woman who works as a groomer in a pet
shop called Kitty and puppy she is
currently going through her routine task
this time bathing a Persian cat named
bedan and styling it as well a short
while later bed's owner Mrs Lee arrives
at the shop to settle the bill for the
grooming service while she pays the bill
soan cradles The Cat In Her Arms and
plays with it right then a shadowy
figure stands by the other side of the
store's glass pane but when soan looks
in that direction it vanishes she
doesn't notice the small palm prints on
the smooth surface of the glass later as
Mrs Lee walks back to her car soan
notices a little girl petting badan but
she inexplicably disappears when a car
passes by upon arriving at her apartment
building Mrs Lee enters an elevator but
its door refuses to close in addition B
starts to grow restless and aggressive
it desperately tries to get away from
her hold this makes Mrs is Lee very
frustrated but before she can take
action the door closes when it opens
again on the 11th floor Mr Lee is
greeted by a grim sight of his wife
lying dead on the elevator floor an
unharmed B meows from the corner licking
its lips as if it enjoyed a meal the
scene then Cuts back to soan who visits
her therapist through their conversation
we learn that she is battling with a
trauma claustrophobia stemming from a
harrowing childhood experience involving
a fire incident when the therapist asks
about her emotional progress she talks
about how she tried riding the Subway on
her own but the fear of the elevator
still persists later on her way to the
Pet Shop soan discovers about Mrs Lee's
death and the police are seen
investigating the scene when she sees
badan she approaches the police officer
who happens to be her best friend's
ex-boyfriend junak she requests that he
hand over the cat to her and he complies
knowing that she has experience with
animals following this soan arrives at
work where her boss is completely
against the idea of keeping bad there he
claims that it'll push customers away
since it came from a dead owner despite
this she puts the cat in a cage and gets
on with her work after a while she
momentarily looks at the window and
suddenly is startled by the sight of a
little girl with cat-like eyes standing
right outside oh no says the girl
however when she double checks she finds
nobody after work soan is walking back
home with badan in her hands during this
she feels a creepy sensation of being
followed by someone but she sees no one
in sight soan lives alone in her
apartment and due to her claustrophobia
she has no doors at her place nothing
eliminates claustrophobia like having no
exits while playing with the cat she
receives a call from her best friend
bohi who casually talks about adopting a
cat amidst of their conversation soan
mentions running into junak earlier in
the day but her friend is unfaced and
tells her that she doesn't mind the two
of them going out after the call as soan
is playing with the cat it suddenly
stares at something under the bed before
making its way in Curious soan peers
under the bed to pull out the cat but
she senses the presence of someone
looking at her when she bends down to
take a second look a ghostly face
charges towards her scaring her heart
out she then lets out a loud scream and
frantically crawls back panting heavily
the following day soan goes to her
therapist and tells her everything
however the latter says that the little
girl she saw can be a reflection of her
younger self aging back to when she
experienced her trauma so why did it say
m soan asks later that day soan and bohi
board a bus heading towards a cat
shelter turns out that bohi is searching
for a long-haired cat in order to
practice her grooming skills however
soan doesn't like this she nags her
friend for being selfish and using cats
as practice tools upon arrival they
discover that the shelter which is
filled with numerous caged cats is Dusty
and somewhat neglected there they meet
one of the workers Mr long who guides
them around the place in the midst of
this so Yan's attention is caught by a
cat that appears to be in a very bad
condition meanwhile bohi comes across
another cat which she finds particularly
appealing and decides to adopt it Mr
long then excuses himself for a moment
and enters a separate room there he
picks up a couple of dead cats and
throws them into an incinerator when he
gets back soan points out a cat that
just collapsed Inside the Cage
regardless Mr long ignores it and walks
out with bohi and her chosen pet as soon
as they leave the door shuts down on its
own leaving so Yan stuck inside seeing
this her claustrophobia kicks in and she
starts banging on the door screaming to
be let out her Visions turn hazy and she
begins to choke spitting out some balls
of fur but before the situation can get
any worse her friend finds her and helps
her up I know you're a vegan but we got
to get you on a better diet she says
meanwhile at the police station junak
and his fellow officers go through the
CCTV footage of Mrs Lee in the elevator
the recording captures bed escaping her
grasp after which she looks in its
Direction with fear shortly after she
falls backward and fights an invisible
force until her final breath with this
evidence the officers conclude that the
woman succumbed to a panic attack the
next evening at work soan stumbles upon
a storage room and finds it filled with
deceased cats through her Terror a hand
unexpectedly emerges from the bodies and
grabs her ankle in a frantic struggle
she somehow manages to free herself and
run out of the place even from outside
she spots the mysterious cat-eyed girl
in the room moments later jinak arrives
and thoroughly checks the place but he
finds nothing a miss being a kind
gentleman he then walks her back home
after going through the unsettling
events of the day soan has a hard time
falling asleep that night when she
finally does she experiences a nightmare
of a decapitated bed and her father she
abruptly jolts awake in a cold sweat but
smiles upon seeing B's tail moving from
underneath the blanket she pulls off the
blanket only to be startled by the
presence of the little
girl the following day soan goes to pay
her father's bills at the psychiatric
hospital but she leaves without even
seeing him afterwards she goes to B's
place where she finds her
enthusiastically preparing to groom her
new pet however the cat appears to be
uncooperative as it scratches bohi and
dashes into the closet as she attempts
to pull out the fashion hating cat she
is confronted by the Eerie sight of the
cat-eyed Girl Again standing by her
closet so Yan who is unaware of this
chilling presence sees the closet door
closing on its own she then decides to
check on her friend in the dimly lit
room where the lights aren't working
when she approaches the closet she
notices a pair of feet among the hanging
clothes as she draws closer and parts
the clothes she finds the little girl
standing freaking so yawn out the girl's
movement then causes the hanging clothes
to fall revealing Boh he's lifeless body
despite being horrified by this
discovery soan acts quickly and rushes
her friend to the hospital but sadly the
doctors are unable to save her and her
body is transported to the morg Via
elevator initially hesitant to enter the
elevator soan nervously steps in during
this she Witnesses blood spreading on
the sheet covering B's body she
frantically claims that her friend is
alive but the doctors ignore her
presuming her to be emotionally broken
soan then lifts up the cover and sees
her friend still dead but as she puts
the cover back on bohi opens her eyes
and grabs her wrist freaking her out as
a result she screams in Terror and the
doctors rush to comfort her where's that
meowing coming from a short while later
junak also arrives at the hospital
visibly devastated by the tragic news
overwhelmed by the loss of his
ex-girlfriend he vents his anger and
frustration on soan blaming her for
everything on the following day soan
accidentally cuts her finger while
cooking as she bleeds B unexpectedly
shows up and begins licking the wound
seeing an evil nature of the cat she
pushes it away only to be met with a
growling
response San doesn't want to keep the
pet anymore so she cages it up and
decides to hand it over to Mr Lee but
upon reaching there the man refuses to
take it back and even offers to pay her
to continue caring for it instead
desperate to get rid of the cat so Yan
decides to abandon it in an isolated
area as she proceeds to walk away she
stum upon an elderly woman who seems to
be lost concerned soan escorts her to
the police station where she learns that
the woman is suffering from Alzheimer's
disease shortly after her son arrives at
the station and takes her home just
before soan leaves junak approaches her
and apologizes for his earlier Outburst
he then vows to delve deeper into the
mystery of the Unexplained deaths he
calls the animal shelter to inquire
about B he cat but the call is abruptly
cut off meanwhile at the shelter Mr long
is seen injecting the cats with Le
lethal drugs and photographing them
before throwing them into the
incinerator however at one point the
incinerator door malfunctions refusing
to close properly as he investigates
he's suddenly pulled by the cat eyed
girl she locks him inside the
incinerator and burns him to
death she laughs on the other hand so
Yan is at her home when she hears some
noise from outside peering through a pee
pole she notices the same toy she once
used to play with bad dangling when she
Squints to take a better look the
Ghostly Girl suddenly appears in front
of her causing her to retreat back in
fear at the same moment she receives a
call from Jun cak who asks her to
accompany him to the animal shelter once
there they discover the photographs of
numerous cats that have been killed
including Boh just then a strange noise
leads them to the incinerator room where
they come across a disturbing sight the
burnt body of Mr long after witnessing
all of these deaths soan discerns a
commonality all victims were found in
enclosed spaces such as an elevator
closet and now the incinerator thus she
concludes that the perpetrator is
incapable of killing in open areas in
search of more answers soan visits the
animal rescue Association where she
learns about the origins of this
Sinister tail it turns out that there
was an infestation of stray cats in the
basement of donga apartment building
when the residents started to complain
about it the doors and windows of the
basement were cemented shut and the cats
were left to suffocate 2 weeks later the
workers removed all the dead bodies of
the cats and incinerated them the scene
then cuts to the pet shop where San's
boss finds badan peeking through the
window he lets it in confines it in a
cage and puts it in the storage room as
he aggressively tries to shut off its
loud
cries the creepy girl appears from
behind and Whispers into his
ears when he turns around she brutally
attacks and kills him later when soan
arrives at the shop she is terrified to
witness the dead body of her boss boss
in the aftermath she vows to put an end
to this madness she makes a brave
decision to investigate donga apartment
building despite her claustrophobia on
her way she encounters the same old lady
with Alzheimer's who is searching for
her missing granddaughter he Jin so Yan
then calls junak to obtain the lady's
address while she decides to follow her
heeding to her request junak examines
the old files and discovers that the old
woman reported her missing granddaughter
9 months ago but her son closed the case
in the meantime so follows the old lady
to her place which happens to be in dong
ha's apartment there she makes a
shocking Discovery a photograph of he
Jin who is none other than the same
cat-eyed girl she has been seeing this
entire time before she can question
further about the matter she's kicked
out by the old woman's son at the same
time she spots badan and follows it to
the building's basement where she's
confronted by a swarm of cats in an
attempt to fight them off soan
accidentally falls into an empty water
tank which sets her in a pan Panic soon
after the cat eyed girl reveals herself
but this time she shows how she died it
turns out that he Jin used to play with
the cats in the very same basement when
she learned about plans to kill them she
tried to hide them in the water tank but
during her rescue process she
unfortunately fell into the same tank
and died with cats surrounding her here
we learn that hijen is actually Halle
Berry I mean the tormented Spirit of the
mistreated cats seeking retribution
against those who harmed them so Yan
being a kind Ed human being is let free
by the spirit in the final scene soan
visits her father in the psychiatric
facility and spends some time with him
while leaving the place she takes the
elevator for the first time finally
Gathering courage to face her fear but
people are still going to get killed by
these cats I don't understand subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching